dr fauci our exalted leader the ruler of
the world
has gotten the coronavirus vaccine
in our nation are saying if dr fauci
gets the vaccine i'm going to get the
vaccine
so tell us a little bit of why it's
important well
for me it's important for two reasons
one is that i'm an attending physician
here
on the staff at the national institutes
of health clinical center
and so i do see patients but as
important or more important
is as a symbol to the rest of the
country that i feel extreme confidence
in the safety and the efficacy of this
vaccine and i want to encourage
everyone who has the opportunity to get
vaccinated so that we could have a veil
of protection over this country
that would end this pandemic okay so
just a little prick and dr fauci is
going to be absolutely fine
immune to the coronavirus that's the
good news the bad news though
in fact she has this bad news there is a
new strain
of coronavirus and that strain is very
likely
already in the united states when you
see something that is pretty prevalent
in a place like the uk there are also
vex uh uh mutations that we're seeing in
south africa
and given the travel throughout the
world i would not be surprised if it's
already here
when we start to look for it we're gonna
find it certainly
it's not yet the prevalent one the way
it seems to have assumed that prevalent
nature
in the uk but we're going to be looking
for it right now
and i'm sure sooner or later we're going
to run into it and find it
now dr fauci says probably as of now the
vaccine covers this new strain too
but you know we got to be careful we got
to keep wearing the masks we gotta
lock down we can't really travel very
much
just 15 more days folks just 15 more
days i'm gonna have a long gray beard
and i'm gonna be telling you
just 15 more days i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from top 10 guy
one who says joe biden probably approves
of this stimulus this covid relief bill
600 was enough to buy a house and three
cars back in his day
that makes sense back in the old days
where the world was just full of corn
pops and malarkey
six hundred dollars by golly that would
get that would get you through your
whole life
but now of course there's been inflation
since the 1530s
and so it doesn't get you quite as far
and president trump's not so happy about
this coveted relief bill
because of that because people are not
prepared to shut down the country
for 11 months and not be allowed to work
and still have your bills coming in and
all this sorts of madness people are not
prepared
you however should be prepared and
that's why you've got to get
ready-wise ready-wise makes being
prepared simple and affordable
order online and have nutritious meals
shipped directly
to your doorstep readywise products are
proudly made in the usa
you shouldn't have to sacrifice taste
and nutrition with emergency food
ready wise uses the finest ingredients
and latest food preparation technology
to ensure optimal taste and freshness
each recipe is crafted by a team of
chefs to provide
delicious nutritional meals especially
during critical times
with a 99 satisfaction rate and millions
of products sold
ready-wise has quickly become the leader
in emergency
preparedness to me this is a no-brainer
first of all the food tastes great which
that's sort of beside the point even
you just want peace of mind you just
want to know
that when things go south and maybe we
all realize that that's very possible
that you are ready your family's
prepared this week my listeners can get
15
off readywise.com when entering knowles
15
at out or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 30 day no questions
asked return policy there is no risk
taking the initiative to get you and
your family prepared today
that is r-e-a-d-y-w-ise.com promo code
knowles 15
to get 15 off you thought
that this whole epidemic was getting
better
oh no it's getting worse
much much worse and according to our
allegedly optimistic
normal sunny president-elect
joe biden america's darkest days
are ahead but even with the changes in
approach
i'm going to put in place in late
january
people are still going to be getting
sick and dying from covert
one thing i promise you about my
leadership during this crisis
i'm going to tell it to you straight i'm
going to tell you the truth
and here's the simple truth our darkest
days
in the battle against covet are ahead of
us
not behind us so we need to prepare
ourselves
to steal our spines as frustrating it is
to hear
it's going to take patience persistence
and determination to beat this virus
there'll be no time to waste and taking
the steps we need
to turn this crisis around darker days
are only ahead if this schmuck makes it
into the white house it has absolutely
nothing to do with the virus we know
that these cynics
these these politicians these sociopaths
who have forced the lockdown on us
they don't believe their own warnings
when you catch them off camera they're
not wearing masks they're seeing their
family they're going to thanksgiving
holiday
at their houses so they can winterize
them their second homes
they're going to the french laundry to
eat michelin rated dinners
without masks on sitting next to each
other and they're laughing at the rest
of us
all of the gullible liberals who are
going along with these ridiculous kind
of precautions
that's what's really going on the door
if dark days lie ahead it's because
of these political scoundrels not
because of anything with the virus
and this is something that drives me so
crazy
about the media coverage of trump what
do you hear donald trump could give
the most wonderful hopeful sunny speech
in the world and
actually he did give one of those in
south dakota
at mount rushmore and the media said it
was dark
and divisive trump he's pessimistic he's
dark he's
angry no president trump is the sunniest
politician of my lifetime
probably the only sunnier politician in
recent memory was ronald reagan
who would say america's best days lie
ahead
and then you have joe biden who says
america's darkest days lie ahead
everyone says trump is fear-mongering
trump isn't fear-mongering at all
trump says we're going to find solutions
don't live in fear of the virus
joe biden is the one fear-mongering
and he's doing it for a couple of
reasons one because
if he gets to the white house he will
institute some draconian policies for
some short period of time
and then he'll claim credit for having
cured the virus
even though he doesn't deserve any
credit for that because we already got
the cure before joe biden
became frankly we got it before even the
election but
they announced it a week after the
election
we already know all of this but he'll he
would claim credit for it and
two because it's a a way to
amass more power and that's what these
politicians have been pulling the whole
time
so if america's darkest days lie ahead
how are we going to get through those
dark days
a lot of people have been out of work at
this point 11 months congress sent them
twelve hundred dollars maybe people got
twelve hundred dollars
earlier doesn't get you very far well
now
we've got a wonderful major important
stimulus
covid relief plan congress is going to
send
some of you 600
for being out of work 11 months and
nancy pelosi says this is very
significant
we also have in the legislation
direct payments which were not in the
republican bill
to america's working families i would
like them
been bigger but they are significant
and they will be going out soon
very significant now look
pelosi she wishes it could have been
bigger how big is this relief bill gonna
be it's gonna be like a trillion dollars
and
another trillion some odd dollars added
on with all sorts of foreign aid and all
sorts of payoffs to political
cronies but you know unfortunately all
congress could find with 600 measly
dollars
for the inconvenience of destroying your
livelihoods for the past
year significant
is 600 significant i don't think so when
we're talking about keeping you out of
work for an entire year
nancy pelosi wouldn't think so too if it
were politically convenient for her to
say what you really thought because i
remember two years ago
do you remember this two years ago
president trump passes this
tax bill this tax reform bill and nancy
pelosi comes out
and says this bill is terrible you know
it gives
tax breaks to zillionaires and
corporations
and that wasn't true the tax bill also
gave about a thousand dollars in relief
to individuals and you know nancy pelosi
thousand dollars who needs a thousand
dollars
that ain't nothing but crumbs the in
terms of the
bonus that corporate america received
versus the
crumbs that they are giving to workers
to kind of
put the schmooze on is so pathetic it's
so pathetic
it is pathetic i hate to say that i
agree with nancy pelosi two years ago
but i do agree with nancy pelosi two
years ago by the way
at the time in terms of a tax bill
that's a pretty good break
but we are now in this unprecedented
moment
where these politicians for their own
political ends
can't forget it was an election year
decided to shut down the country
destroy people's lives even before the
the coronavirus gave them the excuse to
do this
you had prominent left wingers guys like
bill maher who said we need a recession
we need a recession i know it'll hurt
some people but we need it because
that's the only way that we can get
trump out
so and and frankly the left did more
than give us a recession
the left shut down the country
for a year and then the way they're
going to make it up to us
is 600 no i can't tell you how many
letters i've seen tweets posts
all over the place from people who say i
lost my savings
i lost my business my family is really
struggling
and you can take your 600 and shove it i
don't want it
it's just not enough i would i would
much rather and i think
a lot of people feel this way not get
the six hundred dollars
right now even if even if a lot of
people need it and i know a lot of
people who need it
better to not get the 600 than to go
along with this
outrageous offensive bill that is going
to in debt generations
after us first of all because of these
ridiculous spending projects
and that is frankly such a slap in the
face
these these uh elite politicians in dc
members of both parties more than
democrats but some republicans too
saying oh the other the plebeians
they're they're they're complaining
again give them
600 600 what does that come out it comes
out to about six bucks a day
since they shut down the country that's
adding it on to the 1200
that we got early on six bucks a day not
worth it not going to make a difference
they need to veto this bill very
fortunately president trump has
intimated that he will veto this bill
he's just going to stop it right in its
tracks
when you want to stop bad things in
their tracks
then you need to check out axon taser
tasers line of non-lethal
self-protection devices
are small and lightweight enough to
carry with you or in your glove
compartment or purse
they're also powerful enough to
incapacitate an attacker
they use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds
this gives you time to escape to safety
and send emergency dispatch to your gps
location
they also have laser assisted targeting
you can protect yourself and your family
with taser's
line of smart self-defense products
sometimes you know there are regulations
on what you can bring here what you can
bring there
taser you can use it in a whole lot of
places it's
really agile taser is available without
a permit in most u.s states
get the taser pulse plus or a taser
strike light at taser.com with promo
code noel scanner wlas
say 15 now at taser.com promo code
knowles
that is t-a-s-e-r dot com promo code
knowles can w-l-e-s
restrictions apply see site for details
president trump comes out yesterday
over the protests of his advisors over
the protests of
republican leadership in the congress
republican leadership in the senate and
he says
this bill is outrageous and
not good enough for me i'm also asking
congress to immediately get rid of the
wasteful and unnecessary items
from this legislation and to send me a
suitable bill
or else the next administration will
have to deliver a coveted relief package
and maybe that administration will be me
and we will get it done thank you very
much
so president trump goes in and
i love that he's not giving up hope by
the way absolutely love that
he goes in and he describes what is
going on in this covid relief bill
the 900 billion dollar package provides
hardworking taxpayers
with only 600 each in relief payments
and not enough money is given to small
businesses
and in particular restaurants whose
owners have suffered so grievously
they were only given a deduction but two
years is not acceptable it's not enough
congress found plenty of money for
foreign countries lobbyists and special
interests
while sending the bare minimum to the
american people
who need it it wasn't their fault it was
china's fault not their fault i am
asking congress to amend this bill and
increase the
ridiculously low six hundred dollars
to two thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars for a couple
love that absolutely my man let's do it
what you're going to hear
from a lot of left wingers now is wait a
second i
i thought republicans were concerned
about spending too much money
we don't want to spend money on your
stupid investments
which are really just payoffs to the
liberal institutions we don't want to
spend a bunch of money
to study shrimp running on treadmills we
don't want to spend a bunch of money on
all of that nonsense but we do want to
spend money
when you are insisting that americans
not work for a year
so he says this is not going to work
i am demanding that you increase this
number from 600 to 2000
all of his advisors around him were
saying no come on that's not how it's
done
you should have said this earlier when
the republicans were negotiating
i don't care about the republican
leadership in the house and
in the senate what have they done for us
lately
the one good thing i'll say about
republican leadership in the senate
they've given us a lot of judges
not that it's mattered a whole lot but
it's something but for the rest i don't
care good send them back
as president trump says this could be
the
problem for the future administration
but he is not going to put his name on
this trash
and then he comes in and says that
the next administration might be him i
love that
thank you some fight some spine he
doesn't have to give this thing up until
january 20th maybe there will be some
deus ex kraken that comes in before then
you know just that
kraken we were promised maybe something
happens but even if not
trump is going to keep on fighting he's
going to keep acting as the president of
the united states
until the very end i do hope the next
administration is his
because joe biden is a liar
and a crook joe biden
is going out from the office of the
president-elect
and he's giving his sort of silly press
conferences to these fawning reporters
and then occasionally you'll get a
reporter who doesn't just give him
everything he wants
peter ducey from fox news asks joe biden
if the allegations against his son
hunter are russian disinformation
and joe biden oh he laughs and laughs
though
of course those allegations are
completely ridiculous it's all
vladimir putin merry christmas everybody
thank you
do you still think that the stories from
the fall
about your
yes yes god love you man you're a
one-horse opponent
i'll tell you thank you thank you
i promise you my justice department will
be totally on its own
making his judgments about how they
should proceed thank you
first question what is a one horse pony
is that is there any relation between
the one horse pony
presumably a pony that only rides on one
horse
and a dog-faced pony soldier
usually a dog-faced pony soldier could
get on a one-trick pony but i've never
heard of a one-horse pony before i guess
joe got a little confused
how strange huh also also
the hunter biden allegations which big
tech in the mainstream media
spent weeks actively suppressing in
in a an unprecedented way on big tech
they wouldn't even let you
message the new york post article
discussing those allegations out
then later on they said oh look at these
allegations gosh what could those be
those allegations cannot be russian
disinformation
because hunter biden already confirmed
the allegations
he already confirmed that there is an
investigation into his finances at the
federal level
he can the the investigation into his
finances has been going on before bill
barr even got to the doj
it this is another great example where
the biden family needs to get
on the same page with regard to their
lies because
hunter biden comes out says i never
talked to my dad
about my no i'm sorry joe biden comes
out first he says
i never talked to hunter about hunter's
business dealings
then hunter goes and gives an interview
to a magazine and later to television
and said yeah i talked to my dad about
the business dealings
and he said i better know what i'm doing
and then you can actually on the tv
interview
you see hunter biden realize that he
wasn't supposed to say that he goes i
mean but yeah but i didn't we didn't
talk there was no conversation
no conversation and then thankfully the
interviewer actually said
hold on you just told me there was a
conversation he goes yeah well okay that
was it though but that was the only
conversation
so they're not on the same page now we
know joe biden absolutely 100
knew about hunter biden's business
dealings
well same thing here hunter biden's
acknowledging
the investigation joe biden probably
should
too joe biden has been lying
for his entire political career he
dropped out of the 1988 race because he
lied and plagiarized
he's been lying about really serious
things for a long time
another one of these projections they
always say trump's the big liar trump
trump doesn't lie about it trump
exaggerates his crowd sizes the way that
new yorkers talk
okay the way that every single person
that i know in new york
they get sometimes they get a little uh
they like to embellish their stories a
little bit but it's not a lie
joe biden saying yeah my son
hunter's crimes are russian
disinformation that's a lie that lie
matters
that's the liberal establishment for you
when we turn to the woke left i have to
tell you i got to give them a little bit
of credit
because the woke left while they are
radical and they would destroy the
country
they usually don't lie quite they say a
lot of things that aren't true but
they're earnest they're sincere about
them
and they don't lie about themselves you
remember early on when blm
was destroying our country and burning
down cities this summer
conservatives came out and said you know
these people are marxists
blm is an evil marxist organization it's
explicitly marxist actually
and the liberal establishment said how
that's racist that's a lie how dare you
they're not marxist well then we got a
video of the founder of blm
and she comes and she says i'm a trained
marxist that
founder of blm patrice cullors
just came out to clear up the record
am i a marxist take a listen
we're going to talk about something that
i have been accused of
over the last several months it's been
intense at times it's been hilarious at
times
but i feel like i need to set the record
straight am i marxist
i've seen a lot of y'all's comments in
fact
i got them right here do not fall for
their trick
they're pushing a communist agenda i'm
sorry this is really funny
now she's laughing she's mocking this
idea so as you're watching this video
say oh sh
i guess she's not a marxist or she's at
least going to deny that she's a marxist
right because it
you you see the the comment don't be
fooled they're pushing a communist
agenda communist
what would give you the sense that i the
founder of black lives matter i'm a
communist
but then she admits she's a communist
i'm marxist
i'm a lot of things i do believe in
marxism it's a philosophy that i learned
really
early on in my organizing career we were
taught
to learn about the systems that were
criticizing capitalism we were taught to
understand why there were
philosophies that were criticizing
capitalism i'm working
on making sure that people don't suffer
i'm
working to make sure people don't go
hungry and
these comments that i've received have
been incredibly hurtful
it means that so many people who have
listened to people like me inside black
lives matter
and across other social justice
organizations
aren't really taking our work very
seriously but i do believe that we can
get
to a place where there's a
socio-economic system
that doesn't oppress some groups of
people and
only uplifts a few we can't
allow for fear to dictate how we
understand
what's possible did you see that subtle
[ __ ]
i can't believe you're calling me a
communist i mean yeah i'm a communist
and i support communism and i i want
there to be a communist system
and we shouldn't be afraid of that right
so it goes from
we're being told this is all a lie it's
being told people are just
fear-mongering about this actually
communism is great
communism not great bloodiest ideology
ever there was
by my by my account in soviet union in
china all over the third world
that's what we're being told under
communism you understand everybody is
equal but some people are more equal
than others and we're seeing that play
out right now in the
socialist supporting squad there's uh
some members of the squad these radicals
in the democratic party
who want some certain privileges
particularly when it comes
to the vaccine now you can get a special
privilege if you become a daily wire
insider or above member
you can get twenty percent off the uh
the membership with code watch over at
slash dailywire.com you get 20 off that
is dailywire.com
subscribe you get tons of new new
content
all the prageru library including my
show over there the book club
uh candace owens is show at prageru by
the way you're getting candace owens
who's coming to daily wire
you can get apollo 11 what we saw you
get all sorts of stuff
dailywire.com subscribe get 20 off with
code watch
we'll be right back with a lot more
there should be no special privileges
for anybody everybody has got to get
exactly the same
sort of stuff that is what
we are told by these
socialist supporting radicals in the
democratic party and yet
those same most vocal socialists
are the ones who want special privileges
for themselves namely
ayanna presley who is known as the ringo
of the squad
she's sort of the least important member
of the squad she's you know at least aoc
puts on a good show
or even ilhan omar are sort of
cartoonishly wicked and evil
giggling about al qaeda ayana presley
just hasn't been able
to shine quite as well as the other ones
ayanna presley
is coming out now to get the coronavirus
vaccine
even though she's young seems relatively
healthy
she's coming out and getting it before a
lot of older people do
even before a lot of healthcare workers
do
and she's advocating a totally new
arrangement
a list of priorities for who gets the
vaccine
including not just people like herself
but also
criminals yes i did have the vaccine
administered yesterday
uh in in order to maintain the
continuity of government
but also because you know i live with
like millions of americans
i'm two pre-existing conditions um and
and doing my part uh both to keep myself
safe so that i can continue to do my job
to fight for my district and the
american people
keeping my family safe but also uh
stopping the spread
of this virus which has raged out of
control which has everything to do with
the willful criminality
of donald trump and i'm going to
continue to fight for our most
vulnerable
communities who have been
disproportionately impacted by the virus
for our health care workers for our
essential workers
for incarcerated men and women to be
prioritized in the distribution of the
vaccine
wait a second what hold on i totally
expect
these political hacks like ayanna
presley to come and say look it's very
important
for the continuity of government that i
some random congressman more or less
unimportant to the function of
government that i
receive this vaccine before anyone else
does i have to i wish i didn't have to
but i have to
i'm so integral to the functioning of
the government
you could get rid of half the members of
congress wouldn't change a thing
about the way the government works but i
have to get okay you expect that
but then at the end she says yeah we
need to give it to people you know
who've been marginalized who need the
vaccine more than others and
to uh incarcerated men and women and
that's what you need hold on
incarcerated men and women i guess
that's the euphemism for criminals
criminals get the vaccine before my
grandma does are you out of your mind
have you lost your i don't know that she
had the mind to lose in the first place
but certainly if she ever had one it is
gone
no criminals don't get prioritized
for the vaccine we've taken
our understanding of criminal justice
and completely flipped it on its head
you see this most notably on the left
here
where they cry and they wail and they
gnash their teeth and they run their
garments
whenever some triple murderer rapist
serial killer gets his just desserts
in the execution chamber but they clamor
they
they rally they cheer in support of
slaughtering a million innocent babies a
year
that's ex that's not just a little moral
confusion that's a
an exact inversion of of a serious moral
framework
and that's what we're seeing here i'm
not saying you need to torture
the criminals i'm not saying you need to
be cruel to the criminals
i'm not saying you need to deprive the
criminals of the vaccine
but they don't get first dibs are you
crazy
yes this woman is crazy and
i should point out selfish and cynical
because she's taking this vaccine
before other people would get it now
because every once in a while twice a
day
a stopped clock is correct maybe
it's actually a chilly day in hell i
don't know
ilhan omar sort of the most
villainous member of the squad said
something correct
she said something actually pretty wise
she was asked
is seemingly our entire top political
leadership getting the vaccine ahead of
others
because of their age or because of their
importance right they feel that they're
very important so aoc got the vaccine
before
elderly people who need it this woman
ayanna presley got the vaccine before
elderly people who need it
ilhan omar came out and smacked it down
and said i'm not going to get the
vaccine
before other people this is wrong i'm
going to wait in line
and as people who are at greater risk of
dying from the virus
get it after that i'll get it because
i'm young i'm healthy
and the overall survival rate according
to recent studies is 99.7
so that's pretty good and if you're
young and healthy you have statistically
almost zero chance of dying from this
thing
that's pretty sensible i can't i can't
believe i'm saying this but
ilhan omar has been proving herself this
week to be
one of the most sensible members
of the house democratic caucus very
very sad and scary thing now how did
iona presley
justify getting this virus or getting
this vaccine rather before
elderly people who need it well she said
look i have
i have pre-existing conditions right she
never says what the pre-existing
conditions are
she never says how severe it is she
never says what her risk of dying from
this vaccine would be
she never explains why her conditions
make her more important than
elderly people who have more serious
conditions she says look i'm look i'm a
victim
i don't need to explain to you how i'm a
victim i'm just i'm a huge fan look
the incarcerated men and women
incarcerated americans with a hyphen in
the middle you know
also known as criminals they are victims
of the system
you know an oppression and everything
and so they need to get special
privileges
if you can claim
victimhood in any way no matter how
dubious your claims
you can then demand special privileges
you see this very clearly
in a video that went viral over the past
few days of a woman with blue hair
which is i'm not saying 100 of the time
it means you've got a certain political
view
it's just a kind of way
it's a symbol okay it's a it's a way to
guess
it's a way of placing placing bets this
blue haired lady comes out and she says
that a fat people or a victim group
you've got to stop being fat
phobic and we've got to totally reorient
society
to make fat people feel better about
themselves
if you want to be a great ally to fat
people here are some things you can do
when you go to the doctor encourage them
to do the following things
eliminate any weight or bmi cutoff
policies
stop using the bmi completely because it
is ineffective
and racist get medical equipment that
will actually work for fat patients like
blood pressure cups that fit
and won't give a false high reading
because they're too tight set up their
office in a way that makes it usable for
fat people like putting chairs without
arms in every room
when you go to a clothing store tell
them to expand their size range
it does not matter what their size range
currently is tell them to expand it
if you work in education get in touch
with the health and pe departments
ask them if they have anything in their
curriculum that involves students
weighing themselves counting calories or
using the bmi in
any capacity if they do educate them on
how all of these practices lead to
eating disorders and ask them to stop
that's a lot of things to do what would
be the purpose of that oh to be an
ally to fat people
to be an what does it mean to be an ally
means to support
people to to help them out to be
compassionate
but you'll notice the way that the left
has defined compassion
means indulging whatever desires
or appetites pun actually not intended
but
sort of passions or desires or appetites
that people have
at any time that's considered compassion
and
a little tough love or a little
reference to objective reality or a
little
suggestion that maybe people live a
healthier lifestyle
or even as this woman says the the body
mass
index the the medical uh
sort of table that tells you if you're
maybe a little unhealthy or maybe
healthy or maybe this is how you should
change your lifestyle
that is considered offensive and an
attack on someone and not compassionate
not being an
ally and the opposite is true
if you know people come in all shapes
and sizes not everyone's going to be
like a real thin model
nor really should they be but it is
better to be healthy than to be
unhealthy
and if you've got compassion for someone
who's say 500 pounds
then you might say hey maybe you know
work out a little bit or maybe
stop eating you know 20 meals a day or
maybe get into better shape
i'm an ally to you because i want you to
live longer because i want you to have a
better quality of life because i want
you to flourish and i want you to thrive
but now we're not allowed to say that
you see this applied in gender
theory too gender ideology which is if
you got a man
who has this sort of either very very
rare psychological condition where
he's a man and he thinks he's a woman or
he has this kind of
social contagion which is has been
spreading a lot of confusion
that you know maybe there's something
going on in his life and i don't know he
feels that if he pretends to be a woman
that'll make him feel better or
something
the left tells you it's compassionate to
lie to them and say yes you really are a
woman and we're going to
let you go change in the little girl's
room at the public pool and that's going
to be really compassionate that's not
compassionate lies are never
ever compassionate the truth is
compassion the truth will set you free
this is a new standard this standard
completely flips the old standard the
old standard is the truth will set you
free
the new standard is uh only lies will
set you free i mean
really at the heart of all of these kind
of radical ideologies
is the idea of a liberation there's the
oppressive past
the oppressive superstructure the
oppressive patriarchy the oppressive
white supremacy the oppressive
thin supremacy i don't know whatever and
you've got to be liberated from that
and the way to be liberated is by lying
and actually getting back to marxism
uh this is this is almost explicitly the
claim here which is you've got a certain
human nature right now and that's true
but we need to lie about human nature in
order to transform human nature then
we'll have a new human nature and then
everything will be tickety-boo and
that's just not how
it happens and nothing nothing
whatsoever
is uh immune to this
you know talk about redefining standards
the world health organization has
redefined the term
herd immunity so in 2019 you can read
the definition of herd immunity was when
a virus spreads or
whatever illness spreads throughout a
population and then enough of them have
gotten it that they develop an immunity
and then therefore it's not going to
spread as quickly
2020 the world health organization
changed
that definition to saying that it's when
enough of the population gets a vaccine
now that the word orwellian
is overused so i don't i don't want to
use it but sometimes when the shoe fits
the shoe fits
this is this is what they do this is
what the left does
is redefines everything there's this
line in 1984
where uh winston is speaking and he says
you know
every record has been altered every
history has been rewritten nothing
exists except the eternal present in
which
the party is always right well that's
what's happening
and the the part of the left and even
part of the squishy right
has this pretense this fantasy they live
under
that there's the political realm and
then there's science you know and
science is this special thing
outside of politics and so forget we
shouldn't make things political we
should just defer to science and that'll
tell us
how to live our lives and the simple
fact of the matter is that demagogues
and almost exclusively demagogues
rely on science to push their political
agenda
because it's a way of of implying that
your position
is beyond the realm of debate and that
everybody has to go along with it and
the left takes a scientific view of
history and politics
and the right doesn't want to engage in
difficult questions so they want to
defer to science too
and they don't like being called
uneducated and they don't like being
called idiots so
they'll defer to that as well but i
think what the world health organization
is showing you here is that
even science exists within a context why
did
our understanding of modern science even
arise why did it arise here
in the west when it did and it didn't
arise elsewhere in the world at other
times
because of christianity basically
but because of christianity which gave
us
the university system during the middle
ages which allowed modern science to
flourish
because of the christian understanding
of god
who is logic right as opposed to say
allah the god of islam who is pure
will right who is not bound in any way
by logic well
if if you worship a god who is logic
then then
logic and as sort of detachment
objective reality are going to play
a far greater role in your culture in
the way that you understand yourself
in the way that you understand the world
and even even science
will bend the knee to the dominant
cultural narrative you saw this the new
england journal of medicine just did
this
a couple of weeks ago where they said we
a number of doctors there said we should
no longer have sex on birth certificates
because that's oppressive somehow so now
sciences do not
an actual scientific medical journal is
denying
biological sex redefining
standards this is something trump really
really understood
it's why he said my campaign is
basically out here to oppose political
correctness
in 2015 because that is the new standard
it goes by other names wokism whatever
but political correctness is kind of
what we're talking about
and this affects not just science not
just politics it affects even our
buildings and
president trump has just issued an
executive order
that is so beautiful people think this
is a trivial issue
because it regards beauty regards
architecture it regards buildings
actually this executive order might be
the most significant
legacy of the entire trump
administration forget the judges
forget the tax cuts this could be the
long
longest lasting these buildings last a
long time
president trump signs this new executive
order prohibiting
new federal buildings from being built
in anything other than neo-classical
georgian federal greek revival bozars
or art deco styles
thank you thank you thank you so much if
you
have been to washington dc you know
that there there are two washington dc's
there's the washington dc
of the big beautiful the monuments
some of the monuments now i guess the
more recent monuments are pretty ugly
but the older monuments
the older buildings are grand they're
stately they're beautiful
and then there's the hideous brutalist
modern dc of these ugly office buildings
filled with people who are doing ugly
work
for a government that does ugly things
those are the two different kinds of dc
maybe you see this most notably in
courthouses
you have the old courthouses which are
stately
columns ornamentation high ceilings
and you have new courthouses which are
hideous
which are small which are ugly and these
reflect
different views of the law in the one
view the law
is eternal at least long enduring
the law is grander than all of us it's
bigger than
men we are dwarfs standing before the
law
it has it looks in a way like a temple
because in a way it is a temple
it is a there is a religious
significance
to the law to justice right that's the
old version
the new version this small little place
it's like any other office it's kind of
just
reminds us of our homes maybe our
apartment building our office building
and we're going to kind of do whatever
we want here this is just about us
and and you can look the country was in
many ways
uh more serious about the law
more serious about it philosophy
back when we had those kinds of
beautiful buildings
beyond that and this is where i think
some of the
extremist small government people kind
of lose me
is there is such a thing as the public
public spaces and you want them to be
beautiful goodness truth and beauty
that's what you want those those are
that's that's what you're after right
and if you live in an ugly place you're
going to have an often an ugly life
you're gonna
it's gonna affect the way you think it's
gonna affect the way you feel about
yourself it's gonna affect the way you
feel about your country
that's why they built all these
beautiful buildings in the first place
that's why
great civilizations have great buildings
and uh president trump is saying i don't
want these ugly things anymore i want he
initially called this the make federal
buildings beautiful again
executive order he proposed in february
he's retitled it
in the actual executive order promoting
beautiful federal civic architecture
uh and this executive order you know if
it's not
repealed will uh could be very
significant because these buildings
endure a long time now some people
criticize the executive orders they say
well look biden can just repeal the
executive orders trump needs to pass
i kind of disagree with this actually
it's good to pass laws i guess but
the fact is our legislators in the
congress
don't really write most of our laws they
barely write any of our laws
our laws effectively are written by
bureaucrats in the executive agencies
with very little oversight and therefore
if that's where the laws are written
then the best way to rein those in
the best way to try to effect some
political change
is through executive order right because
you're directing the agencies and the
agency is the ones writing the laws
maybe that's not the way the
constitution set it up but that is
practically the way things are working
speaking of new federal buildings by the
way
we're about to get two unfortunate
federal buildings
the smithsonian's a women's history
museum act and the national museum
of the american latino act were just
folded into
into the massive legislation that was
put into the coronavirus relief and
government funding package
this is one of the many reasons that
this stupid bill should be shot down
we should not have a women's history
museum or a national museum of the
american latino
not because women and latinos don't
deserve recognition
for things they've done but because
to separate the women's history museum
and the latino history museum
from the american history museum is to
imply that women and latinos are not
american and that's exactly what
the leftist cynics who are pushing for
these stupid buildings
are trying to imply they're trying to
say yeah this america has excluded all
of you you have nothing to do with
america we're all very different
we all need to remain divided so that we
on the left can conquer you mike lee
senator from utah totally gets this and
and explained the problem with this
legislation
as he was conveying against it
for that reason the smithsonian
institution is more than just another
line item
in our federal budget it's one of the
great
cultural triumphs of our republic
from the moment of our founding the
united states has faced an
almost unique problem in history
how do we turn our huge nation's
cultural
religious ethnic and regional
differences
from a potential weakness into a real
strength
the way our nation has always achieved
this is by creating institutions that
unite americans
around shared interests and the mystic
chords
of collective memory the constitution
the senate itself our free enterprise
economy
our armed forces and public schools
federalism
localism the first amendment and even
march madness all fit this bill
they have the power to harness our
individual and community differences to
the common good of the whole nation
totally right he gets it this is an
extraordinarily insightful take
it is simply a fact that human beings
are tribal
uh it is simply a fact that a challenge
in the united states
is that you've got lots of different
tribes first among the colonies between
different uh
religious groups then and also different
ethnic groups from within northern
europe then different ethnic groups from
including southern europe some of whom
didn't like one another the italians and
the irish didn't like each other very
much
then different ethnic groups from all
over the world and this persistent
issue of slavery which became rather
racialized during
especially during the 19th century and
so you've got these
different tribal groups how do you all
get along common religion we don't
really have a common religion broadly we
have
we have broadly the common religion of
christianity but there are some
exceptions to that
we've got common language sort of not as
much anymore
we we don't have common race we don't
have common uh
sexual desire i guess would be a new
differentiator today
so how do you all come together well
what lee was doing there was referring
to
a line of i think abraham lincoln right
the mystic chords of memory this idea
that we all have to come together
to agree on the idea of our country
the traditions of our country the
history of our country we need to
hold that up we need to support that we
need to believe in that sort of thing
and unfortunately
on the left they want to divide that up
either you will come together as
americans and say we all support this
country
you know you won't protest the american
flag you won't burn the american flag
you'll say well we
at the very least the one thing that
unites us is that we're americans
you've got the mystic chords of memory
to use the old phrase you've got
trump's phrase that we all bleed the
same red blood of patriots either you
will have that
or you won't have a country because of
human nature because of the
unique history of this country very very
bad idea
to to continue to push these divisive
sort of buildings and ideas
i'll give you an example of one of the
the clear ways that uh
that we're all sort of finally divided
up
very few people believe that this
vaccine
is safe just 49
of americans most people do not believe
that this vaccine is safe
why is that is it because of the science
is it because
of the way that this was rolled out
perhaps i think it's because we don't
quite trust the country anymore
we don't have faith in our institutions
we'll have to leave it there
for today we'll get more into that
tomorrow do we want a country do we want
to have a country do we want to be
together as a country
or do we not well we're going into a new
year are america's brightest days ahead
or are our darkest days ahead suppose
that's up to us
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there